that whole thing's crazy you need to go
to a lawyer you need to hire someone to
do it prenups are are are good I guess
they're good to for both parties but
they're a legal matter you can't just
print up a template this whole thing is
so Bonkers what's what's he what's the
craziest is that he was crinkling
something for is not the craziest thing
it's the most annoying
part
Runk hello hello
hello hello will pleas
hello
hello hello do you think anybody likes
looking at themselves more than you yeah
I do actually who do you think it is uh
I don't like looking at myself are we
going I don't like looking at myself
what do you like doing that's not
something I like I would I would be I'm
on the Bottom Rung of that that's not
what I like then how come when you're
watching yourself you don't close your
eyes I like watching myself what's the
difference your hair looks
good
why why does your hair look well what do
you want to talk about what watching I
don't like watching myself I like I like
listening to myself and if it's a video
I will watch it because I want to
understand the bits that I do and I want
to understand them even better than I've
already done them and and my hair how
much do you like looking at
me I like looking at you thank you uh
yeah your hair looks good hair looks
better possibly better than it's looked
in years all right right now well okay
it looks like it's just kind of you're
hanging out and it's like it's good it's
good length it's good like it doesn't
look like you just washed it but it
doesn't look dirty it's a 10 yeah it's
like a nine and a half all right well so
if it's one of the best I've looked it's
looked in years and it's obviously got
to be a 10 okay but here's the thing
okay for your hair it's a 10 okay so
then then hairwise I could only get a
9.5 in the world of the people with the
greatest hair yeah I mean that's not
even insult
have the worst hair you know what I mean
I know or best hair I get it that's not
even interest saying you have the worst
hair this is oh what's going on you
turned it off no I made it lower oh
that's that you wore that the first
episode of Lifeline yeah dude I remember
I did I remember I remember what is that
from don't know but it's from something
whatever do matter it's it doesn't
matter it's almost a JW with the SL um
but if we don't know what it's from we
can't have it be a listen um it's
episode 84 what the Frank it's
Thanksgiving week what the Frank Sundays
are for Lifeline what the Frank dude you
can go to uh patreon.com Lifeline luxury
to sign up for the lifeline luxury
podcast which is absolutely Frank and
unbelievable grow or die is available my
special my fifth special it's on
chia.com we love it it's uh you guys um
I really appreciate you watching it it's
doing stupid numbers so uh do idiotic
numbies no it's doing really well uh I
appreciate you go get it at chia.com uh
I will be in Trenton Philadelphia
reading Oxnard and I just put on sale
Sacramento Sacramento where you at I
always think of that that's Dr Dre uh
Phoenix Arizona Phenix I always think of
that
Phoenix uh and uh El Paso Texas and
Albuquerque New Mexico and then I have
more dates coming up next uh I think
this week I'm going to post them I'm not
sure but uh just had to work out the
marketing and all that so go go to Chris
lead.com I'm going to be there can't
wait to get back to Phoenix man I love
love the Celebrity Theater love it it's
in the round and your boy gets seen from
all angles but uh
also if you want to submit to the
private record which is Matt's new
podcast yeah uh where people share
amazing crazy weird wild stories uh go
to uh the privat record.com and if you
have a question for Lifeline just drop
uh Down Below in the link we have it uh
watch lifeline.com and we got the merch
at Lifeline merch.com it's all you know
it's all how it is baby you want to
one-onone with me go to mata.com thank
you you want to one one want one one one
one one with me matalia go to mat.com
thank you you want to submit to my
podcast get yourself on the show go to
private record.com thank
you so stupid and don't forget about the
merch go to lifeline merch.com and thank
you you're 40 dude um I am 40 so I was
working out
yesterday and I was thinking about this
cuz I took d love very fantastic
comedian we right uh my always in a
terrific mood dude he's just the best
man um and he was like I want to work
out legs cuz I work out this was in LA
yeah this was yesterday yeah in La he
was like I want to work out legs well no
I he didn't say that he showed up ask
because you go on tour with him I yeah
he go um no no we traveled to another
city to work out but um no he goes on
tour with me but anyway uh he he was
like I'm here I I put a guest you know
he doesn't go to my gym so I give him a
guest pass came up and he's like what
you working on today I said legs he said
I knew you're going to say that cuz you
didn't want to yeah nobody wants to work
out legs nobody does I actually do but
you like it I do yeah I've grown to like
it okay because it's so hard oh okay
right um it's like kind of you know what
it's like kind of going
to meetings like uh for addiction it's
like once you start doing it like I've
just now I've done eight meetings in 8
days so every day I'm doing a meeting
yeah and just now I'm like to I woke up
and I'm like I got to get I got to get
to my meeting you know what I'm saying
but when you start doing it you're like
uh but what about is
it during and after do you feel
increasingly good about it or you just
in leg leg day or or meeting day if it's
like if it's similar meeting is
uh well it's to it's a totally different
thing I mean it's just completely
different but the meeting I guess the
meeting is really what I'm asking about
because I don't care about leg day
obviously
you know much more well meetings are
cool because you share your feelings and
you hear other people's uh uh um what
they're going through and you identify
with some of it you know what I mean and
some some of the meetings are you you
don't you identify with them less you
know they're going through different
things completely but uh uh leg day is
always just hardcore so anyway I was
anyway I digress but I was doing so we
start doing it and um I was working out
and I was thinking I I you know because
he works out but he doesn't he works out
yeah no he does he got he's fit but he
doesn't work out legs hardcore he does
work out legs but not I feel like a lot
of people don't they don't yeah it's
just you know you do it half people want
to look good they don't want to like
model their legs you know so uh we did
it I went hard and he's obviously he
texted me say I'm in pain but uh I was
thinking about I wonder what the heck it
would be like with you me yeah oh I did
not think going but doing actual a leg
day with you be miserable for
everybody involved I would be miserable
and ostensibly you would be too because
I'm like absolutely murdering the vibe
i' be doing my thing oh then it would be
fine for you too i' be doing my thing
yeah yeah I would be doing my thing yeah
no it sounds it sounds just you know
unfortunately like a complete utter
nightmare okay so if I was like all
right your turn come on let's go you
would be like no you would look up and I
would be gone I mean like I just and I
don't want to get I don't want it to get
confused by anybody like I don't think
people who do that yeah I know that it's
just me like that's not for me yeah wow
dude yeah wow how much do you
sleep uh I guess lately more I guess so
maybe six and a half seven hours oh
you're getting more yeah lately I get
more okay cuz you used to get what like
five going to die Bing early yeah it's
not good yeah you got to move around and
you got to sleep more I mean I
definitely move around no no no I know
you move around L you Pace work out I
know I wonder though I wonder how if I
wish we knew how much working out and
eating right and sleeping right
affected uh our the longevity of our
like I wish there was an app where you
could see like you're doing well at this
point if you do this you'll live to
92 but what about when you get hit by a
bus or just that's always the but what
if you're coded for genetically to get
cancer when you're like 6
these things don't but but but like the
way you work out people are going to be
so in disagreement with me about this
but like sometimes you just are going to
get the thing you're going to get yes
that is true but but my point is if if
like what if there like I'm saying that
would be amazing yeah what if you could
add that you could add the blood test to
it and then your app says you know
you're supposed to get this at well dude
eventually one would have to imagine
that something like that will be in
existence and and available to every
single individual and that's what I
wanted to come in if you would just pay
a small fee uh I can help with that I
think probably you this is like Theos
what do you mean oh you I was thinking
about Theos too yeah I'm saying if you
just give me a small you're you're
Elizabeth homes for this app okay
$220,000 I think I could prob make it
happen anything about any of this but
did she I know more than you what do you
mean I know more about how the stuff
works than you do and I'm not interested
stuff works
body Stu what would go into an app like
that what are you talking about oh yeah
yeah yeah okay I thought you meant
health and fitness I was about to be
like um wow yeah I was about to be like
check please and we're not even at a
restaurant so how's how annoying ex this
um sure dude I me it's definitely
annoying unless you're Ace Ventura yeah
well then it's good yeah then it's good
so anyway uh that's what I was thinking
about um maybe that's boring but
honestly I don't give a dude I do
what I do it's not that boring but I
want everyone to understand what Chris
did he went to the gym with Denny love
his friend and while they were doing leg
day he Chris thought I wonder what it
would be like to do like day with Matt
right that's
weird but it's not boring so I don't
it's not boring I don't I think that's
in
strangely strange and odd that's strange
and odd let me tell you okay so if I was
if the story was I went to Dole day with
Denny love mhm and I wondered what it
was like to do leg day with in the
middle I wonder what like to our friend
you know Rob would that be interesting
no so you only say that cuz it's you
right well I'm saying to the audience it
might be interesting because we're the
host of the show they watch the show
they care about us he got out of that
one he got out of that one got out you
know wasn't in anything you were
involved you were involved in you were
in the storm I was in hot water yeah
okay dude the other day Calvin uh was at
um the the Grove with our Nanny and he
asked our Nanny he said um are are we
close to home and and she said no well
not too far about 10 minutes away from
uh mhm from uh from home and he said
stupid and and then he said
um I can say stupid now because I'm not
allowed to say it at home because Mommy
doesn't like when I say stupid
ooh got it out of his system at the
Grove working it out got out of that one
from at home how funny is that dude
that's pretty good I got to start doing
that kind of stuff more often when
you're not at home say say words that
yeah like saying like I don't really say
words though that like I've never yeah I
don't ever call there's no like word
that Christen is like don't say that
word cuz some some some guys would get
mad at their woman and be like B I don't
do that I've never done that actually or
CU N You Know How It Ends but I don't
that I never done that never called her
a name in my life yeah I don't yeah
can't call Nam D Frank dreon that's a
good thing to call someone that's not
calling someone you know who Frank Dre
is of course I know who Frank dreon is
Leslie nielson's character in Naked Gun
yep almost called it Top Gun uh Hey what
if nli Leslie Nielson was in Top Gun it
would be better we all know question
what did you guys watch the killer on
Netflix not but I want to I did yeah
that's by that guy that's what that guy
uh what's his name in it oh is that a
Fincher movie yeah yeah it's Fincher is
that a Fincher piece yeah it's a Fincher
piece we'll talk about that on luxury
but oh yeah okay
yeah I did see it yeah okay yeah
Lifeline luxury go to get Lifeline
luxury yeah that's a little teaser I'm
going to tell you what I think about the
movie The Killer I don't like oh I'm not
I'm not subscribed and they're going to
run to patreon.com Lifeline luxury just
to hear what I think about the I I like
uh oh man you know what my favorite
daavid finer thing was what we could
talk about the sun Lifeline oh even more
wow it was man it was that that one on
Netflix though that was happen well
they're all on Netflix now but that's
mind Hunter mind Hunter yeah mind Hunter
yeah all right um okay let's start you
want to go into it can somebody get me a
bottle of water hi Matt everybody at
Lifeline you guys are awesome um I need
some advice so I played volleyball in
college and now I coach Club volleyball
and give private lessons great and most
these kids are like middle and high
school MH and at private lessons
sometimes the parents will sit on the
court and like actively give feedback as
I'm giving feedback private lessons the
thing is that they're usually wrong and
they're kind of mean to their kids like
they're a little bit harsh and get in
the kids heads and I can just see them
start to spiral so how do I tell these
parents like stop and you're wrong and
you're making it worse for these kids
but also you're entitled to be here on
the court you're paying for the lesson
your kid it's a free
CCH um yeah I'm just not really sure
what to do thanks fre that is tricky I
will say that that is tricky because you
under normal circumstances you could
just say the flat truth because it
doesn't matter but this is like your
actual employment you don't want to lose
clients by by delivering news to them
that they're obviously not going to take
well but at the same time I agree with
you that they're sort of it's suboptimal
to say the very least that they're there
doing that like messing up and going
against probably the things you're
saying or at least pulling them in a
direction that is suboptimal robot um
did she say volleyball yeah she did what
is a private lesson for volleyball is a
team sport I didn't want to go down that
okay all right keep going but I guess I
get it like there's private lessons in
baseball I know but the baseball is a
very singular thing you a lot of times
you're batting well I would imagine
they're doing things like she's setting
someone up and it's like how do you
spike and how do you do setup it's like
technique what's weird is that a parent
who doesn't play volleyball would think
that they know anything about that's
actually that's so crazy well maybe
maybe it's like I remember when I used
to play baseball like there would be
dads who thought because they played
when they were younger that they knew
better than coaches and it's like sure
that's possible but it is just very
unlikely that you know more in this case
especially than the private coach that
you've hired for your child but parents
dude parents get weird they act like
entitled I'm going to be like well I pay
for it so I deserve to be here and and
it's my kid so I can say it's like yeah
that's true but if you want your kid to
be better at the thing then you got to
let me do my thing from the thing you
should be like oh you don't want your
kid to be
better you're throwing money away just
say that oh good dude yeah oh good I
can't get this out of my
throat you done yeah you done being
disgusting so I'm try not to dude but um
yeah you know what also you could do is
set set that out from the jump like make
it in the email or whatever like by the
way um you know
sometimes parents get involved and they
don't know what they're talking about I
mean you know obviously make the
language nice but uh this is a
one-on-one thing for a reason so let me
do the teaching you know what I'm saying
and if not I have a particular set of
skills I'll find you and I will kill you
yeah that that's a good one and then a
picture and a gif of Liam niss you know
what's weird it is GIF what do people
say GI everyone says GIF and anyone who
says anyone who says GIF gets corrected
and it's hard how do you know what it is
it's like swimming so hard up because I
saw I don't remember if it was an
interview with or an article the guy who
yeah the guy who coined it oh really
yeah Fred GIF yeah
Tom Tommy JF yeah but but here's the
thing I'm probably gonna agree with what
you're going to say because it stands
for graphics or graphical interchange
format it should be it should be GIF it
should be GIF you're right I'm just
saying the guy who made it up calls it a
gif trffic and that is that is just the
fact it stands for giraffes and
heat
honestly that's oh this the H is silent
G yeah draft drafts in no
heat is one word right so G FH
oh oh heat right okay
scientific word imagine giraffes having
sex and then thank God animals don't do
oral sex because what if giraffes did
oral sex their body would be so far away
from the actual person person you
know uh yeah I think long ass neck on
the the other giraffe just get a long
ass neck can't even reach with the just
yeah their body would be in like another
zip code yep it's like raining where
their body is and not where their head
oh why you so wet because I went no no
no because I was an a different zip coat
why you all wet baby yeah uh what I
think that do you think about the fact
that some animals do give oral sex oh
well yeah and receive or sex right
humans and then also uh bats and uh
sloths and also fish and um wolves
sloths dude just like
this and when they come they go oh it
takes 10 10 and a half minutes yeah yeah
all right the jiz is like yeah I didn't
fully listen to what he said but I think
what he said was the right kind of
advice you got to just in you got to
thread the needle but you canot say
something I think the way it has to be
framed
like you can even say like the stuff
you're saying is great and I think that
maybe you can if you can save it all up
for after the lesson we can maximize our
time together right something like that
I guess I still think that you should do
it before anyone does anything you
should do it oh I see what you you
should do it in the email beforehand or
whatever it is like this is remember
this is one Gess you have the language
nice you know you're nice come if you
want but yeah right it's a one-on-one
lesson and then also if you do come try
not to try to resist the urge to cuz you
know to say something cuz I know my
and you don't well that's not like that
possible way to say but she's obviously
a nice lady right yeah that that's
that's the move I think and then if they
still do
it you can always resend the email then
that's tricky though like what if they
yeah exactly you do you could forward it
back to the person and then just write
whoops over it parents would still do it
dude for sure they will still do it then
you're in an even trickier spot cuz it's
like I already yeah but you can't you
can't make people do something so if
they're going to do it they're going to
do it period but but the best thing you
can do is say hey look don't do that and
do it before they do it so they're not
defensive yeah right yeah now are they
listening to haunted house footage or
something what's going on yeah I don't
know do you guys hear that mhm oh it's
above us it's above us oh it sounds like
it's in the speakers oh yeah people are
moving stuff just above it's haed house
all right cool next
one hi boys uh thanks for taking my
submission okay I need advice so my
partner and I
have uh been together for 5 years we
have a little boy he's 2 years old we
love him so much C we um decided
to split recently uh we can't afford to
live in separate homes so we're living
in separate rooms in the same house
wow pause there any advice awesome
second bit of that we have an incredible
sexual
connection um that's like so incredibly
hard to jeez um put to rest so with all
that going on need advice need help with
boundaries need what do you think we
should do can't afford to live on our
own living in the same house raising our
son in separate rooms strong sexual
connection go thanks I got a good piece
of advice stay together yeah you're
together like what the what what's the
reason you're splitting stay together
because you are together yeah oh man
what do I do okay so I'm with my I'm
with my
we live together we have sex so much we
love each other we laugh so much we have
a beautiful child and we love raising
him um and how do what do I do what the
hell do you're doing it what the hell do
I do what is it maybe it's a situation
maybe somebody crossed a boundary and
then it's just they can't get over it or
I don't you have to imagine what
whatever it is that's that there's a
good reason but but based on what you
said you're together and what you should
do is try it out try to work it out
because you already are together I mean
I you're together yeah you live together
ens you are consistently having sexual
relations and you have a child that you
both adore that you co-parent like
you're together yeah and it's also fine
to sleep in different rooms that yeah
some couples just do that actually even
like I know no I married are happy so
you can still do that and then also like
how if you're not together and you can't
live in different houses then honestly
how is your dating life like you you
can't invite people over it's too you'd
have to explain too much to the kid and
there's another reason why you're you're
together together so I would say in all
honesty well first of all just because
of all the things that are stacked
against you like don't be hard on
yourself if you like can't stay away
from him like or he can't stay away from
you like of course you guys are going to
end up having sex if the chemistry is
amazing you guys either have been still
are or whatever you're you're in love
yeah they're probably in love like you
know don't be like oh what's wrong with
me I keep getting into his bed or I keep
letting him into mine like that's
clearly going to happen be easier on
yourself about it and if you guys really
want to separate I I really do think
that you have to figure out a way yeah
to not live together that's really what
you both want you have to do that right
100% um
otherwise that's a
really yeah I don't I guess you know gez
yeah to even say like we recently split
is almost like well you didn't though
you didn't split because you're under
the same roof having sex and
co-parenting a child you both love that
is I mean are you like not having meals
together are you not talking in you know
you are right you are I would imagine
you are and in front of the child you're
obviously like at least I would hope so
like getting along in front of the child
yeah yeah yeah not thrown together
now you're together hey hey you know
what you're together you're together and
here's the here's the crazy part you're
happy yeah hey yo you know what I I keep
wearing this uniform with a badge on it
it's blue I have a hat that says police
and uh I'm not a cop so what do I do I
arrest people um I put them in jail they
let me and frankly the cops let me put
them in the real jail I hang out with a
bunch of other real cops um and I go to
all the Christmas parties for the real
cops people address me as officer I have
a DI from cop school that lets me
officially police communities yep what
do I do I'm not a cop
yeah that's the same question you're a
cop yeah you're a cop you're a cop yeah
okay all right cool next
one
hi I mean so cute that's a good point
what are you talking
about hi I'm Natalie this is Nick hi
Natalie and Nick my question is about
his
name um
he is almost three
he was a complete surprise oh he came um
surise
surprise and um you have to name your
baby within I think like eight weeks or
something after I named him I realized
that his name should be Clarence
oh after Christian Slater in True
Romance oh that's cool is it
completely and totally Jackie to change
my baby's name after he is almost three
I don't know but he's a Clarance look at
him that's hilarious right
Nick his name is Nick why why do you H
what's the eight weeks thing uh legally
you have to officially uh put forth the
name of your legal name of your child by
8 week they give you eight weeks to name
your child just start calling him
Clarence too you don't have to
officially change it to be like hey
Clarence oh that's mom did that
that my real name is
Jeff I mean you don't have to like make
it such a thing to where it's like but
here's the thing though you certainly
can yeah know I I think you should his
name is Nick you should keep it Nick
that's what you think yes that is what I
think I don't think that I think if you
want your child to have a different name
because it is re has been revealed to
you now that you've lived with him for a
long period of time or know enough time
and that child strikes you as someone
who should have a different name means
nothing but okay no it does mean
something dude I've I mean I don't mean
to compare people to dogs but many
people adopt dogs keep the name that
they've always had and they're just like
you're not that though you're you're
something else makes no difference I
don't agree at all anyway I agree with
my brother though if you just want his
name to be clearance you don't need to
legally go through the whole thing but
if you want to go for it dude but it's
not necessary you can just be calling
him Clarence in doce him as clearance
and people will learn that he's Nick and
be confused as but who cares no
dude Clarence is a name just as much as
Nick is a name if I started calling
Calvin you know Terry MH he would be
like why are you calling me that it's so
weird it's it's going to affect the kid
he he didn't seem to mind too much well
yeah
well he you know they would say Clarance
and he would go gay yeah I know but it's
just like you you it's been three years
yeah three years it took you too long to
figure out your name son's name well
maybe she's been wrestling with it for
two years yeah in which case it's too
late it's too long though it's too long
but I like here's my problem with this
whole thing I like naming him Clarence I
like the name after a Christian Slater
character but Nick is a great name to
romance Nick is a good name I have
nothing against the name Nick I'm just
saying Clarence is obviously a less
common name yeah uh and it has meaning
to her clearly
and she thinks he's a Clarence and not a
Nick I I get that I can relate I would
not do that I don't think ever but I
don't think she's in any kind of wrong
it's too old you're going to confuse him
I think you name him Christian Slater
from TR romance that's what you name
what if you just named him n
nlar it all Rose together Mo it all you
know you know your name is actually
short for cl or you could if he doesn't
have a middle name you just be like your
middle name is Clarence what called
Clarance
too it's all the same thing it's all the
same call him Clarence if you're going
to do something just start calling him
Clarence but don't change it legally
that's just too much and what if he's
like oh man why didn't you name me Nick
when he turns to be 15 he's like I like
Nick better well when you're 18 you can
change your name to anything so that
kind of is it's kind of cool though to
be growing up to be like like as a
30-year-old to be like hey Clarence
should be like you know that wasn't
always my name like that's pretty badass
to have that story too see so then
change it to Clarance give your son
something to talk about whatever we're
giving you a lot of probably be boring
if he's like most people in the
world give him something to be less
boring sck
anilist we're gonna die anyway
Chang U all right Clarence seems very
sweet CL so good luck I always think of
Eminem I mean I think of Clarence Thomas
I third so I don't know yeah me too I'm
smart I think a lot of people will or CL
Clemens cuz I'm
musical what's up Matt what's up Chris
been a viewer since the beginning and
I'm down to do trivia to prove that nice
uh but for real I love you guys you guys
have gotten me through a really hard
time and I can never repay you enough
for that wow uh I need some advice
though give us got this girlfriend we've
been dating for about 4 years she has a
brother he's 27 I'm 26 I'm 6'2 he's 5'9
nice but regardless um he's over
affectionate with my girlfriend and it
needs to be stopped and I don't know
what to say or what to do every time we
meet up uh he gives her like a big hug
and a forehead kiss and he has a pet
name for her he calls her MooMoo he says
I missed you MooMoo uh and then he's
like overprotective and oh that's he
just whines about the weirdest things
towards her uh when we leave he gives
another forehead kiss and a bye MooMoo
um but the other day we were on the boat
me my girlfriend her brother and the dad
and he ate a we were all tuckered
out at the end of the day her brother
was off doing something so we just said
bye to the dad and we kept pushing um
maybe an hour or two later we get a call
from the Dad that says her brother's so
pissed off why that she didn't say bye
to him oh no that he didn't get his
precious by moooo forehead kiss and
that's really what threw me over the
edge but here's the
caveat he's such a sensitive guy and the
dad is such a sensitive guy and the mom
is such a sensitive lady so I can't make
things too awkward because they'll never
talk to me again like if I I can't
properly just call him out and say hey
big dogs around no more
forehead right no more moomo we're all
adults here uh I can't really do that in
a too aggressive way I don't know what
to say any advice would be appreciated
again love you guys what an interesting
thing life rips yeah it does I I wonder
what she thinks well that's what I was
going to the talk to your girl and ask
her or not ask her don't foot
around around it just be like say big
dog around listen you're look look
you're talking to big dog right now okay
it's just you and big dog
okay look it's just you and big dog so
we can just you know we don't have to
each other okay big dog don't
okay
and do how do you in all honesty how do
you feel with like the level of
affection your brother displays for you
and the we like the overprotectiveness
that he displays hey look look it's me
it's just big dog and Mumu face to face
big dog and Mumu okay I'm your brother
right now imagine I'm your brother and
then get down like this like real like
low you know cuz he's 5'9 like first of
all how does he get well she's probably
shorter yeah um just be like do you like
the forehead kisses do are you Mumu or
are you my girl right maybe she doesn't
like it the the pet name thing I don't
who cares I was going to say not a thing
I mean siblings call each other
like that all the time yeah yeah I call
weakling I call him boa bang bang bing
bing weakling and boa bang bang bing
bing uh but um no bully you know
weakling so dumb and an alien Bing
binging Bing um but I don't
uh you know the forehead
kiss that's kind of odd that it's always
a forehead kiss to me agree it's one
thing if you're I don't care about that
but like that's a weird it almost that
makes it feel like it's a weird
ownership thing or something or
definitely some sort of insecurity thing
I don't know but um the overly sensitive
thing is is terrible I mean you're just
being a big just being a person big dog
and if you were to just say yo it makes
me
uncomfortable with the way they're
treated and then it was fine but what do
you mean he's pissed off that she didn't
say bye sometimes you just don't say bye
to somebody ever heard of Irish people
and like you know like it's okay you
know not you don't be like get over it
but like
we're all adults big dogs around and
it's
fine yeah uh I think that for the for
him to say I don't want to make a big
deal it because they're never going to
talk to me again is that's crazy people
in her family are clearly way too
sensitive okay now obviously you want to
accommodate for that as much as you can
cuz it's they're your girlfriend's
family you love your girl but at a
certain point you cannot continue to
accommodate someone like that like you
or a group of people like that you
can't you can't you're big dog dude you
can't constantly be Shackled if you're
big dog you can't big dogs do not you
can't be Shackled too much right not
yeah exactly you you're going break fre
of those chains eventually because
you're big dog yep if you're a big dog
you got to be the big dog unfortunately
it's your nature yeah so I I mean it
sounds like you can at least take a few
steps first to avoid a potential
confrontation MH first and and obvious
and I'm I'm stunned if you haven't done
this already big dog you you have to
talk to her your girl about it frankly
tell her your feelings and ask her about
her own if she she might even say
something that might even put your mind
at ease and it's like actually it's like
this and you think about it like a
different way it might even make you
feel differently about it talk to her
about it she'll understand if you're she
already knows you for four years she's
not going to be like whoa where's this
coming from from you're never like this
she already knows you're a big dog right
you know yeah definitely talk to her
about it if you haven't done it yet yeah
that's step one but even if you have
talked to her about it like talk to her
about it in a in a different way this
time and just be like look it's it's too
much for me at this point and I want to
talk to you about figuring out a way to
help me deal with this is it me talking
to your brother is it you talking to
your brother is it all three of us
having a conversation I don't want it to
be as you know I I I want want to
minimize the potential sensitive
reactions by your family but like I'm
totally down to be as you know direct
about it as I can be but I don't want to
overstep anything that's going to make
you feel uncomfortable CU obviously and
this is you to her like you're the most
important person in this situation to me
I want to make sure anything I do is
okay with you and it's all good that's
weird the whole thing is kind of weird
you know I none of it would bother me
until the that phone call then would be
like all right so so I agree with you
what phone
call that that the brother got mad oh
right and the dad called it's like it's
so iMed and I want to know if the dad
was like on the brother's side or like I
don't know what to tell you but your
brother's mad and I don't I don't know
that's different you know Dad was like
look why didn't you call you should have
said goodbye to your brother now he's
upset and it ruined his day like in mesh
oh you guys are babies dud been
babies you're all babies yep how's the
mom feel too uh like the last episode
you're all babies find a big crib big
dog needs to find a big crib and fit the
entire family into that Big crib okay
well there have it and then close the
top of it so they can't climb out a cage
yeah all right
cargo let's do it yo what's up
Chris that's a great beard so here's my
question Chris I will sell you my hair
for
$125,000 w that's a bad de now here's
the thing I literally just woke up so I
just want to show you you know this is
just an even playing field you know what
I'm saying this is just the canvas okay
right a lot to work with there yeah yeah
so my question is I will sell you my
hair for
$125,000 thank you we have the same hair
I
guess not really no why would I want his
hair it's good hair sure but my hair is
it's the same hair yeah I like my hair
better than his his beard is killer his
beard he should have offered his beard
I'll tell you what well maybe the
Beard's included is beard is the beard
included he didn't say so I imagine it's
not I don't want that beard I think it's
great but I don't want it that beard
would look crazy on me if I had that
beard dude people would be like what the
the is going on beard is so dense
that beard is so dense that if you stuck
your finger in and pushed hard you might
not get to his skin yeah you know what
I'm talking about yeah it's like a Brill
pad yep he it's like it's like a velcro
it's like not not hair no they shot they
shot Deliverance in that beard yeah they
did it's got a Creek in it people are
lost inside the beard right now they
shot lost in there is what they shot the
smoke monsters in there yeah yeah the
taes are all all up in the back who the
taes what oh you know the Lost yeah I
know about the taes oh that's pretty
cool I forgot about the w wow so
anyway so good hey mat Chris um to keep
it brief I have recently decided that I
am not going to be drinking anymore just
because um every time I do I wake up
with a headache
um my body just doesn't respond to it
well and even if I don't drink enough to
get drunk I still wake up feeling crappy
so
um but because of that
people people say really weird and
invasive things when when you tell them
that you're not drinking for some reason
like oh are you an alcoholic um to my
or are you hiding the fact that you're
pregnant from us because God forbid I
just don't want to drink alcohol like
you know of course there has to be like
this big secret thing um anyway but the
reason I'm bringing this up to you guys
is because I'm very curious what you
guys would say in those like bar
scenarios and stuff um when you're
telling them that you're not drinking um
and they come back at you with some
weird like pressy stuff or um making you
feel bad for not drinking in the being
invasive anyway she said to keep it
brief I'm just curious I'm say what you
guys think of that and um yeah thank you
so sweet joking with you but you did say
to keep it brief you can't say stuff
like that about someone who's being so
sweet she's so sweet but she said to
keep it brief and then it was 4 minutes
and it's all good she's very sweet it
was a minute it was a minute but it's
all good all right well what I'm saying
is yeah no I'm kidding but there there
is uh what she should do is just say it
might even be true you don't know cuz
you always getting headache just be like
y I figured out I'm like allergic to
alcohol oh interesting because like it's
not even really a lie if if you if
you're always getting a headache
afterwards just be like yo it gives me a
headache I'm allergic to it and the
thing is you'll get in people be like oh
really like what is it that you're
allergic to the Hops yeah or whatever uh
um I know what you could do say to me
like well what what you're drinking
tonight no I'm not oh how
come don't want to okay and that'll
definitely get them to stop talking to
you but then you'll be known as the
in
town she's so sweet imagine her doing
that that woman don't want to she would
do it like this don't want to um sorry
you okay that's what she would do yeah
no you you that would if you don't want
to ah dude it's really annoying I mean
he never drank I stopped drinking
so people that know me yeah I mean I
used to drink a lot too and I didn't you
know quit because of
Any internal reason it wasn't like I was
I mean maybe I was an alcoholic I
actually don't even know you just kind
of stopped but I just stopped for a a
health reason uh a long time ago and to
explain that Health reason would have
been not only take too long it would be
really boring and I'll sum it up the
doctor said his penis was too small for
for the doctor said you know gosh you
have this tiny penis situation your
penis goes in and I was like well what
do I do about that they were like stop
drinking so I stop drinking uh and now
it comes out just Peaks Peaks out a
little bit it's still really small uh
from inside my body and um no I I I
actually I preempt anything so when
people are like what are you drinking or
can I get you a
drink I'll say no and if anybody comes
at me with more even just a look I'll
say I'm not like an alcoholic or
anything I just don't drink if you if
you put out a Vibe like shut the
up it be hard for her they will shut the
up it' be hard for her I know but
it's not mean though I don't mean like
be a dick I mean it's like if you put
out the vibe of like you don't want to
know about it I don't want to talk about
it it's boring like it's I'm not an
alcoholic I just I don't drink that that
is enough in my case always no one's
ever been like oh but what happened you
know it's just like that guy doesn't
drink and they can think oh what a
bore oh what a kill Joy but
that's on them dude even when I used to
drink a lot if someone was like no I
don't drink I was never one of those
people who was like oh oh think she's
better than me or like come on just have
a like they are like that that those
people suck though those people suck
just be like well y y let's have a drink
and be like uh oh yeah no oh you don't
drink why not I just don't drink oh yeah
well what's going on how come did you
stop or something be like did you ever
get an abortion and be like well what
were you doing do get personal be like I
just figure since we're getting personal
I get personal with you and then and
then just dancece away yeah like facing
them but like your shoulders are
bouncing um I think it's yeah it's
annoying that's one of those things that
everyone's always going to have to deal
with when they don't drink but just say
you're allergic to it that's what I
think dude you think I'm a beanie guy
maybe let's find out you certain don't
know how to put one
on let me see it seems so ridiculous
yeah you kind of don't you don't you're
not h a hat head person I'm definitely
not a ball cap guy beanie May maybe not
a pink one it just kind of is
silly me here's the thing if you wore
them sometimes you would look okay I
would have to get people used to it yeah
so so so really that's not something
that it's not like I'm not a beanie guy
it's well it's exactly like well I'm not
a beanie guy but exactly I don't look
bad in beanies do I look bad in beanies
is what I'm asking no I look bad in a
lot of baseball hats I will say that I
look bad in them it's not that I'm not a
hat guy it's that I look bad I am not a
hat guy but it's the fact that I look
bad in a lot of baseball hats not all of
them okay okay I don't think I look bad
in these but I think it's a jarring
because it's off it's so off brand for
you because I don't because I don't wear
them you know what I mean yeah and
that's fine wow it doesn't matter going
to talk about it in therapy next
time about do you think that it's I
could wear a beanie
doctor all right yeah that sucks and we
both obviously sympathize and can relate
nip it in the
bud nip it in the bud tone of voice Vibe
just let it be known without actually
saying the words let's not talk about it
it's boring oh yeah C oh yeah all over
okay all right next next all up Chris
what's up Matt the hair uh big fan
what's the hair got some te for you some
advice whatever your thoughts so my best
friend of 20 years is getting married
and he has never heard of a prenup
before I had to be the guy to bring it
up to him uh I guess that night he went
to his lady printed out a prenup and she
didn't want to sign it printed out wow
when she didn't want sign it what did he
do he said oh it was my boy's idea he
put it on me so ever since then she's
been real standoffish you know we're
trying to do double dates and all this
playing pot chips best man his wedding
Jes uh yeah what's your guys' thoughts
on that what's your guys' thoughts on a
prenup um he's 29 she's 36 he just
started his
business I told him it's not just for
men it protects both parties what's you
guys' thoughts yeah well your friend is
a idiot if he's never heard that
had to have been he's never heard of in
your words a preown I had to be hyper
hyperbole there's no no way that he
hasn't heard of a prenup I mean I'm
taking Al I would say guys with that
hair that he has definitely probably
know people that don't know a lot of
things and guys that have no idea that
crinkling something that much while
recording anything isn't going to
up the recording this guy that might not
be his fault he probably isn't on camera
a lot let's let's give this guy that
let's not give him the fact that you
should cut your hair his hair doesn't
even bother me I kind I kind of like his
hair it's short and long in the back I
know it's kind of cool have it long or
short in the back I'm not even worried
mullet is fine I thought he's got a ret
tail I thought his Hair gotat Co no he's
got a rat tail I'm not going to
lie just to join your Club of bashing
his hair I'm not going to lie just to be
a part of your hair bashing Club okay so
what's his question his question is how
would you handle it now is girl now that
guy's girl thinks he's a well
the dude is a He's made
which guy the other dude what do you you
mean how oh it was the guy who
told me to do it well also he printed it
out you need a lawyer you need to do it
legally you can't just be like and she
has to promise not to take all of my
money control P like dude dude that's
not what's control P print yeah dude pra
Google Google p r e n u m p
print it's one it's half a page and it's
got all the places like not filled out
like the blanks and yeah it says
wow dude that's just that whole thing's
crazy you need to go to a lawyer you
need to hire someone to do it prenups
are are are good I guess they're good to
for both parties but they're a legal
matter you can't just print up a
template this whole thing is so Bonkers
what's he what's the craziest is that he
was crinkling something for so long that
is not the craziest thing the most
annoying part he didn't watch it back
and think oh my God I'm crinkling so
much no he either did watch it back
didn't realize it or didn't watch it
back he does those two both of those two
things are absolutely ins guys who have
short hair in the back and long hair in
the back don't know things I mean
clearly you're right but have friends
who don't know things in isolation if
we're going to take each thing in
isolation I'd like his hair but I'm not
denying that that okay is true okay okay
so what you should do
is first of all I don't not not sure how
close you are to the guy's girl
but tell the
dude to throw you a bone dude
cover for you a little bit though it's
not your it's not his fault here it's
not your fault here's the advice I would
ultimately give you yeah who the
cares man I guess she's going to get
over it she's not like you didn't like
call her a gold digging piece of or
something you just said in the prup it
says that get a prenup gold digging
piece of preup man it bothers me
that it was throwing an m in there what
what M he kept saying prenup and I was
like maybe maybe I'm just hearing that
but then he said it before I even said
anything he was saying pren nump yes
wasn't he yes we both thought it short
hair and long hair in the back yeah look
I like the hair in isolation but it
might come with a suite of other
characteristics including saying prum
including not knowing that crinkling too
many things while you're recording
something ruins it he just had
cellophane yeah he's just like so hey
guys so I just wanted to talk to you
about
prenups it's like this
I mean was what he did he reached over
for I know I know um I don't I
that's what if it said prump on the top
of the thing that he printed out you
know he write on the header it says our
prump it doesn't even have their names
me and my girls decided we're going to
split it period the
prenup contrl
P te prump to prum instead of the
there's no h just so up went to
Homer Simpson law um all right dude uh
yeah that's whole thing is crazy
that it's not your fault how is your if
he's never honestly if this dude's never
heard of a pre-up then he's got way
bigger issues that's that's crazy what
that is no but here's the absolute
truest possible thing if he never heard
of a prenup he 100% guaranteed does not
need a
prenup because he's a idiot and
he's not going to accumulate a lot of
money in his lifetime oh it's still he's
starting a business he said yeah a
business of being a dumb okay not a
good business dumb Incorporated
that's his business I would definitely
want to know what that is it's good
marketing good marketing all right yeah
next one next one
hey Matt hey Chris uh need some advice
I'm a uh teacher um nice and the teacher
that teaches next to me uh right down
the hall um thinks we're best friends
and I'm not a not a big fan of this
person don't have anything against their
character just they're kind of annoying
and always want to have conversations
with me and always want to you know come
in during my room on our lunch break and
you know talk about mostly complain
complain about students and co-workers
and things like that and sometimes I
just you know want to chill by myself
but also don't want to be a jerk and Dr
whatever so um Dr yeah any advice on how
I can tell him to chill and leave me
alone while not being a douche to him
you know yeah okay uh well this is a
common theme I think in our uh in the
show we get one of these types of things
every so often so it leads me to believe
that this is like a
pretty universally relatable problem the
the person at work that thinks they're
friends with you when you don't want to
be friends with them at
allh I think in your situation because
you're a teacher and they're a teacher
and it's kind of just dependent and it's
not technically teachers don't even
really have to interact with each other
unlike most job situations I think tell
me if I'm wrong you have license you
have more latitude to be an actual dick
about it what than what than someone who
like shares an office with someone oh
them all the time and they take
conference conferences together or
whatever you know what I mean this you
can be like I'm not saying you should do
this but you have the right to and I
don't think it would come back to bite
you too bad if you were like look I
really appreciate my breaks alone like
if you don't
mind uh leave me the alone wow you
know yeah or just say you're
grading papers
dude I don't but that you can't say that
every time you could no no I think no I
think you need to do something that is
going to last got it you can't have you
can't be like every single time you need
a new excuse cuz you're a liar it's it's
like it's like americ like I got to
return videotape yeah it once and then
it will never be weed again yeah true
but what I'm say lay it down lay it down
once yeah but then it's weird when you
see them and stuff not really if you
don't care create an enemy keep your
enemies close keep your friends close
your enemies close doesn't apply at all
doesn't even remot big big believer in
sunsu in The Art of War man wow okay say
that was that from him sunzu the enemies
thing friends Clos enemies closer yep
sunsu okay well okay well actually I
think it's Michael Valley m m Valley
Michael Valley I think I think Michael
Valley said that is it m Val that said
that or is it sunu no it's
sunu I'm very cultural I'm very
historical keep your friends close keep
your enemies closer was your
friendenemies inside your
butthole I think that might have been
Maki it was sunsu yes dude I'm so
smart here's the thing about
that The Art of War I got the Art of War
because Tupac Chang is named to
makavelli and it was from Ma
and I started listening I started
reading Mai and then I started looking
at sunsu but that is not right he didn't
mavi didn't write I but I that in that
world of of stuff I was kind of you know
what I mean it's like the same universe
in a way like how Avengers are you know
oh I got into Spider-Man cuz I got into
Superman that kind of thing okay okay
you were worried about the beginning
being boring that wasn't boring this
that was boring I truly think that that
was not boring okay so we dis we agree
to disagree agree to disagree but I will
say though that The Art of War was not
good and I will also say that he was
that was one of those things remember
back then I'm not saying it wasn't good
I'm joking but like back then wrote Art
of War yeah okay but back
then was it
really smart to say those things or was
it just he was the first guy to do it
you know what I'm talking about well
it's still smart to say those things
it's smart keep your friends close to
enemies closer no the whole thing I'm
not that not just that keep your friends
close to enemies CL is a very smart
thing to I guess come up with it's not a
smart thing to just be like oh that's
dope I'm going to say that too no so my
point is is sunu really the kind of guy
who comes up with keep your friends
closer enemies closer or is he a guy
that kind of maybe heard someone else
say it and be like no it's kind of dope
I'm going put it in my book sunzu
definitely didn't
hear other people saying anything he
probably came into contact with like 80
people in his life back then it's not
like you hear other people saying things
you know a pigeon could have dropped it
off what yeah Pig they yeah yeah maybe
but I don't think that happened either
by the way do you ever believe that that
ever would work ever worked I don't ever
believe that worked put a note in the
pigeon and fly it to another town I
believe it worked but I can't I I can't
believe that humans actually figured
that out but yeah that was a real that
is a real thing I believe it never
worked
once oh okay you put it yo the
they're coming to get you yeah yeah oh
well I actually don't even know how
that works that's a good point but I
guarantee you it it has worked you know
no not once I hate when they do that in
movies when it and the window still and
the and the oh what's this oh a
handsome Su like that doesn't really
happen that often in movies you know
what I mean every single every single
movie where there's castles that it it
almost happens and like fril stuff yeah
it doesn't happen like Ben Stiller
movies but I'm just saying like
yeah that that's never worked once and
we are led to believe that that's worked
and that's never worked once we'll get
to the bottom of it on on luxury okay
okay all right we'll really research it
and everything uh let's get one more in
though before this ends okay we got we
got one he guys love the podcast uh
Chris and mat love what you're doing uh
Chris will be send you in Richmond
Virginia November so question for today
I share the name of an extremely famous
athlete um someone who no longer playing
but but was huge when they were yeah
Lord Perry every time I meet anyone it
always comes up they say oh you used to
play for you know some kind of corny
joke oh no I work with a lot of like
white collar guys so I can't slam them
into Oblivion like I like to um so any
tips you have to deal into that what can
I do to kind of get back to these guys
and just let them know like yeah you
know you're not being original here
that's sucks all right thanks guys
appreciate advice what sucks is like
imagine your name was for real
like Bobby Bania Samy Sosa yeah like
it noar Garcia para like it Jose cono
would be incredible yeah sucks it sucks
and also what were your parents thinking
although it could have happened to where
they didn't know it was going to happen
right they could have named you before
the guy got famous of course but he said
he doesn't play anymore so one would
believe he was probably around the
parents probably just didn't know no
yeah um but that being said we only said
baseball players which is great I was
just going to say that but we're
interesting yeah yeah manb you know his
OJ Simpson his name is manb very famous
uh believed murderer to some and
murderer you know well he you know no I
know never was convicted no he certainly
wasn't but but but pretty much think he
did it he did
it and every and everyone knows it um it
could have been his son dude OJ
Simpson's son you see that conspiracy
it's pretty wild there's a there's a
conspiracy theory that there was a
serial killer at that time and was
purportedly in that area and there's a
whole book really written about it I
think there was even a TV movie made
about the book that posits the theory
that it was in fact a serial killer who
killed Nicole Brown and Ron Goldman what
isn't that crazy whoa yeah the the you
guys look up the sun one it's pretty
wild especially like me being a dad i'
be like oh actually I could see that cuz
like if the kid the kid had a little bit
of some issues and then went crazy and
then the dad's like I did it
same DNA anyway who's his
son Tom Simpson no I have no idea BJ
Simpson is uh wait blowob what did this
person ask about oh the name uh yeah I
think what you do it's similar to the uh
not drinking thing you introduce
yourself and you and you without being a
dick just be like haha I know it's this
because you don't want to let the person
think they're going to be clever here's
the thing about that it's bad for
everybody the person that thinks they're
being clever it's bad for you obviously
because you're so sick and tired of it
but it's bad for them because it makes
you think that person is just a
idiot like everybody else who thinks
they're clever so like you do you have
you have an incentive to nip it in the
butt you want to like new people that
you meet and they're putting themselves
in such a hole when you first meet them
by being like Oh Mark Maguire Hey Big
Mac you know let me check those arms
you're on steroids like there's going to
be some joke that they fold in about the
Superstar athlete that whoever the
it is I think uh just is just P like
just P yeah just say you're that guy who
cares well he yeah that's me man great
I'm Tim Duncan no he works with people
he needs to be professional I know are
you still think I'm Tim Duncan man yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got it dude I'm I'm
uh Robinson what's the guy's
name David Robinson
wow David Robinson dude he was the
man huh yeah damn his hair was
real that's me dude I'm o
camboy oil can boy wow uh jaylord Perry
that's the first one you said right yeah
that's what I said
so so it's all good I'm Dennis SLE all
right look you can go get grow or diey
the special my fifth special it's at
chia.com uh and uh our patreon Lifeline
luxury is a uh
patreon.com you want to be a guest on my
podcast what's up my new podcast coming
out you got a crazy story you got a wild
story you got a story you want to share
with the world go to the privat
record.com submit yourself as a guest to
come on the show and tell me that story
thank you very much uh yeah you know
Chris is on tour going to
different places like Trenton Phoenix
who cares and uh you want to one-on-one
with me go to mia.com
wow you have a question uh hello click
the link in the description below or
obviously go to watch lifeline.com to
get on this show or leave us a message
at the hotline you don't even need to
show your face wow uh and of course if
you want the merch go to lifeline
merch.com and buy every single piece of
it in every single size or you hate us
you know dude uh I got new dates go to
chris.com thanks very
much
hello
hello hello
please
hello
hello hello